one of my first forays into genital
studies was looking at ducks I
discovered that they have this
incredibly dramatic erection
in a third of a second the male birds a
20 centimeter long penis and ejaculate
and this is something that that wasn't
it certainly not known and that nobody
would have guessed in a million years
the next question that popped into my
mind was I wonder what the females look
like because you can have a penis like
that without having something going on
in the females and when I dissected them
I almost fell out of my chair
literally because there was this
incredible labyrinth of structures in
the vagina and when we look at the
histology of of the female ducks we can
see that the females have much thicker
vaginal walls and so essentially they
have reinforced their vaginas in order
to be able to withstand these ballistic
penises without rupturing which is of
course important if you're a female duck
and so we email somebody who works on
ducks for the industry you know more the
commercial side of it we said have you
ever seen these weird structures and he
wrote back and he said wow I cannot
believe it this is you know this has
been here all along obviously but the
way he would dissect the females he
would always just skip through right
whereas the way I was dissecting it was
I was unwrapping it because I figure I
got to see what's underneath and so I
just couldn't believe it but it was I
think in part because I was coming in as
a woman I was asking a question that to
me seemed pretty obvious right and it
just
apparently hadn't been obvious to
anybody else I was ill then